hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren epic jump map diesem app
heißt tropical zusammen mit dieser
person
es gibt mal wieder eine neue app und
allein schöner name wirklich operation
tropical vacation ja gar nicht also wir
sind wahrscheinlich auf ihn dann island
wir spielen auf normalpapier sollen spaß
haben blabla
genau hier hakt es because i can you
also es ist abend tragen und zudem
gerade noch so wie heißt sie kann
überhaupt nochmal und hier steht ein
schild hier unten wo ist aber wie heißt
das überhaupt noch mal so gut wie heißt
auf jeden fall operation raccoon also
jetzt unsere aufgabe ist es hier wie
urlaub zu machen
mehr oder weniger das ist doch schon mal
ein guter anfang
auf jeden fall erstmal schauen was
passiert es mir kommen einkommen komme
ich hoffe es gibt vier punkte steht doch
bestimmt hier oben oder also immer
wieder habt ja ganz normal dass wir das
abwechselnd hochladen und so ganz genau
spricht der nächste fahrt kommt wie auf
dem einen kanal sprich der dritte part
wenn es doch eintritt im park geben wird
wo kommt der kräuter gekocht er bekommt
er so ja bekommt er natürlich schreibt
direkt aufeinander
er kommt bei konkreter wird wir bei mir
ist ganz einfach so schulz kennen wir
hier sind geil ich habe vier stück
verwundert ich hab noch gar keinen
hunger obwohl ich da oben runter
gesprungenen hielt points alter krass
challenge accepted huskies online ist
gastiert collect direkt mal los was sind
das hier sind da schon welche aus
schwerter leisten sie etwa 20 hatten
waters wort nice ok rüber mensch wir
spielen in der app liegt am projekt
schlimmste aber ja ich möchte möglichst
schnell mal ein paar gas treten erstmal
kriegen hier geht's lang yeah you found
glory hole in die hall mit flip flops
allein schon dass man mir noch gar nicht
erwähnt es gibt hier mal wie ein neues
texture pack für dein eigenes sag ich
mal meine füße meine füße
nein ich habe den roman du bist
behindert wortes dich ja solche machen
ich möchte mit kommen no go forward ins
stadion menschen
ich möchte kisten ja ich muss da immer
eine kiste sein
wir sollen loren benutzen
jetzt droht ich habe alle produkte
kaputt als er hier der komplette kader
nachfahre hier die tolle strecke ja ich
auch da kommt einer herrlich
ich wollte weiter wo ich mir die nächste
kiste ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich
glaube wenn man stirbt wir werden nicht
mal die items inventar liegen
sprich wenn du stirbst und eine amoktat
ist da kann ich die einzige stelle
hingekommen scheiße auf welchem spaß
machen
auf den grünen zweig
dann hole ich mir mal hier schön so ein
drink und der hoch geschlagen das neue
formular oder war lava der welt bei
einer reingefallen ich hoffe doch nein
wir mit deinen ganzen scheint schon
wieder
du kannst weil wir in laverton projekt
omega projekt nehmen übrigens vielleicht
auch noch wollten ja einige dass wir
damals zusammen aufnehmen da wolltest du
übrigens zaubern beibringen und ich die
energie irgendwie so oder hast du schon
energie branche ich habe jetzt ein und
kam hierdurch neigt man nicht doch kann
man buch beschließt
ich dachte du findet jetzt wieder das
risiko secret behind the painting was
ist das ihr schaden drin jetzt kann ich
nicht rollen nicht gut
er kommt nein siebtens paradox wenn ich
will gleich gut lass das war bitter weil
wir auch machen gegenseitig töten
verboten java unterstützt und so darf
man sie sonst zwar klar klar aber nicht
so dass der anderen stirbt
ok nein damit wo ich dachte ich schon
jetzt schon da denkt ihr komme dann auch
mal denke ich da auch mal nach gut was
ist jetzt los vorbei jetzt vorbei jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt jene wie stumpf des
gerade wenn sie wird sie noch da müssen
wir darauf mein schwert es durch gar
keine hier darauf müssen auf jeden fall
abwehr dann hier
a ja okay ich weiß aber ich dachte nicht
ich auch man das sehe ich nicht ein aber
hier liegen keine items wie habt ihr
auch behalten geil
ja toll schade man muss eigentlich gut
ich meine ich möchte nicht wissen wie
oft fehlt oft später sterben wirst ich
glaube wir werden jetzt erstmal stern
mal wieder zeit nicht gegen diesen block
fire unter wandeln ja doch mal nicht ich
verstehe das nicht müssen wir wirklich
daran
ab hier na klar das war knapp hättest du
mich nicht geschlagen und allein schön
du mit deinen schon das sind flip flop
flip flops aller das gegenteil ich war
drauf hab es leider nicht mehr geschafft
habe ich darauf gekommen
komm ich geb dir anspruchsvoll gut ich
dich ich gehe ich komm ich hab dich an
nein so weit geschafft
er wartete auf mich du bist du dich mit
weiter gesprungen willst ja punkte wo
seid ihr die welt geworden
hier ist bett
ich habe es auch geschafft okay okay
hier schlafen gehen
darum ist auch bleibt drauf ich schlafe
oben nötig gehobenen entdeckt einfach
mal die leiter nicht helfen euro machst
du 'ne echte auf das meist nicht auch
einmal sonne kommt wäre das glaub ich
versuchte meinen draußen klettern von
der seite und die wir anstatt über die
leiter zu benutzen bisschen kiste und
eis ok checkpoint klar dass du schon da
weiterläuft kiste da oben waren wir
gerade darauf dass man alles essen
wir müssen sterben ich stehe als erstes
weil ich trinke ich ertrinke mich hier
in alter überhaupt nicht deshalb so
nette toilette nein nicht ertragen ich
möchte dich töten
er kommt würde ich könnte mich
regelverstoß gefängnis megaprojekt was
ich mir start okay der check
funktioniert nicht aber er hat noch
einen anderen meine ich hatten wir ja
toll aber trotzig kein gehör jetzt nicht
ich hab da ein geöffnet
ich hab' ich drauf gedrückt worauf auf
den checkpoint
ich gucke ich nicht weil ich genau hier
wird der jackpot gewesen
krefter man hier wäre gewesen die du
doch mal eben kurz in den kopf
ich möchte da oben halten transporten
ist wieder oben 18 euro
schon wieder bekam system fertig im 1
was war das
ich wollte mich zu dir telefonieren noch
aber wichtig zu mir teleportiert er weil
du denn alle befehle gespeichert hat ist
auf von hin naja gut machen wir nochmal
er hinter offenbar darauf einmal creeper
komme wobei keeper direkt hinter der
wand reaper hinter mir war kein creeper
ok probiere es aus wenn wir oben wieder
runter gefallen geil
voiceover punkte swatch group gmbh hoch
hier uhr melonen wasser hier ist von der
projekt ruhig richtig ruhe zwei punkte
ich habe schon viel letzten werden die
ersten sein freunde und was ist das für
eine große mann
wir müssen da hoch meine ich
findest du direkt bekommen direkt jetzt
hier
danke schön findet erst mal wieder
direkt eine kiste ach so geht das ab
lasst doch mal rein
das ist doch unfair komme ich so viel
porten hallo rego und freibier später
wieder gebohrt es sich dauerhaft guckst
auch noch kisten und auch am weg wo wir
hin müssen ja ich weiß wo wir hinmüssen
darunter nein hier
da oben ist das ist gäste drauf
offenbach auf dem dach drei punkte 33
mein freund drei städte 333 punkte
die ersten welthit letzte sein
du sagst es okay scheiß auf komme ich
jetzt alleine rum
ich hab sie im punkt übrigens kannst du
auch gerne titel schreiben sie haben
konsum trainers so stand involviert in
eine neue karten staffel macht macht
macht schon wieder echt spaß hier
ja ich finde auch also macht eine menge
spaß einfach mal die augen offen halten
nicht immer hier mit verbundenen augen
ins spiel
ja ich bin ja schon viel weiter habe ich
finde keine kisten haupt nicht so denn
genau da wo du auch bist ok links rum
wenn da steht links heißt das recht
kiste ist ist es nicht ich erstmal schön
hier einen halben kilometer geflogen na
na na na na so lange in guter form ist
mir dann aber ich finde irgendwie das
ist richtig chili gebaut richtig schön
gemacht auch das texture pack ja also
das texture pack ist ja mehr oder
weniger default etwas leider ist müsste
michael heck
erst das ist hier schon die erste
schwierigkeit sage ich mal bei dem
ganzen spaß man jetzt davon
wesley mensch das wollten mal machen
sollen lasst es geht darum wieder an
werden
du wirst mich doch etwas wiedergeben
getötet roboters kleinoden ich werde
sogar auf der seite an der duh
unterstützten kiste
aber hier ist bestimmt woanders eine
tour im ring ring ring ring wo bist du
hier und da unten
nur ein punkt eindruck noch packt er hat
die map daisy web show erforschen
durchgegangen
das ist doch echt ich habe sie steht
laut apple dazu finden sie den punkt es
geht er auf dem schild steht the troll
ansehen dass ich geiler sack es ist
nicht einfach nur wieder unfair wenn dir
sagen weil das machen wir es mal kurz
ein stopp weil wir sind schon wieder an
der anzahl an bekommen moment ich sehe
da keine kisten kammer buch
fischer nur bücher bücher bücher an
glück sehr schön mit spleens heißt das
wenn es euch gefallen hatte vorschlagen
wir machen an der stelle hier wirklich
nennen folgen katja es wenn es euch
gefallen hat las gerne ein daumen hoch
da für die weiteren folgen die nächste
folge kommt bei mir ist verdammt wald
bei gomez und die dritte damit bei mir
mit